Mr Speaker the president of the United
States
[Applause]
you know I start tonight by
congratulating 118th Congress the new
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
special recognition to someone who I
think is going to be considered the
greatest speaker in the history of the
House of Representative Nancy Pelosi
story of America is a story of progress
and resilience
of always moving forward of never ever
giving up
the store unique among all nations we're
the only country that has emerged from
every crisis we've ever entered stronger
than we got into it look folks that's
what we're doing again
two years ago the economy was Reeling I
stand here tonight after we've created
with the help of many people in this
room
12 million new jobs more jobs created in
two years than any president's created
in four years because of you all because
of the American people
two years ago
in two years ago
but had shut down our businesses were
closed our schools were robbed of so
much and today covert no longer controls
Our Lives and two years ago democracy
faced its greatest threat to the Civil
War and today though bruised our
democracy remains unbowed and Unbroken
into my Republican friends we could work
together the last Congress there's no
reason we can't work together and find
consensus on important things in this
Congress as well
folks
New Orleans has formed as I am but I
think the people sent us a clear message
fighting for the sake of fighting power
for the sake of power Conflict for the
sake of conflict gets us nowhere
that's always been my vision of our
country and I know it's many viewers to
restore the soul of this nation to
rebuild the backbone of America
America's middle class and to unite the
country
we've been sent here to finish the job
in my view
folks my economic plan is about
investing in places and people that have
been forgotten
now some members here are threatening
and I know it's not an official party
position so I'm not I'm going to
exaggerate
but certainly to repeal the inflation
reduction Act
as my coach
that's okay that's fair
as my football coach used to say lots of
luck in your senior year
make no mistake
if you try anything to raise the cost of
presenting jobs I will veto it
look
for the last two years
my Administration has cut the deficit by
more than
1.7 trillion dollars
the largest deficit reduction in
American history
under the previous administration the
American deficit went up four years in a
row
because those record deficits no
president added more than the national
debt
in any four years than my predecessor
nearly 25 percent of the entire national
debt that took over 200 years to
accumulate was added by just one
Administration alone the last one
they're the facts check it out
check it out
[Applause]
how did Congress respond to that debt
they did the right thing they lifted the
debt ceiling three times without
preconditions or crisis
they paid American bills to prevent an
economic disaster of the country
so tonight I'm asking the Congress to
follow suit
let's commit here tonight to the
full-fated credit of the United States
of America will never ever be questioned
so my many some of my Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage I get
it unless I agree to the economic plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans some
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
[Music]
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you a copy
I'll give you a copy of The Proposal
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see you now I tell you
I enjoy conversion
the programs the way they are that go
away other Republicans say I'm not
saying it's a majority of you I don't
even think it's even a significant
but it's being proposed by by
individuals
I'm not politely not named
look folks
the idea is
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved into being threatened
to default on the debt if we don't
respond
join us tonight are the parents
Tyree Nichols
welcome
as many of you personally know there's
no word to describe the heartache or
brief of losing a child
but imagine
if you lost that child at the hands of
the law
imagine
having to worry whether your son or
daughter came home from walking down the
street
playing in the park or just driving a
car
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk that brown and black parents
have had to have with their children Bo
Hunter Ashley my children
I never had to ever talk with them
I never had to tell them if a police
officer pulls you over
turn your interior lights on right away
don't reach your license
keep your hands on the steering wheel
imagine having to worry like that every
single time
your kid got in a car
here's what tyree's mother shared with
me when I spoke to her
when I asked her how she finds the
courage to carry on and speak out
the faith of God she said her son was
quote a beautiful soul
and something good will come of this
imagine how much courage and charity
that takes
it's up to us to all of us
we all want the same thing
neighborhoods free of violence
law enforcement law enforcement who
earned the community's trust
just as every cop when they pin on that
badge in the morning has a right to be
able to go home at night
so does everybody else out there
our children
have a right to come home safely
equal protection
under the law as a covenant we have with
each other in America
we know
police officers put their lives in the
line every single night and day
and we know we ask them in many cases to
do too much to be counselors social
workers psychologists responding to drug
overdoses mental health crises and so
much more
in one sense we asked much too much of
them
I know most cops and their families are
good decent honorable people the vast
majority
they risk
and they risk their lives
every time they put that shield on
but what happened to Tyree in Memphis
happens too often
we have to do better
[Applause]
we're doing everything
says to replace
health care we Safeguard patient safety
but already more than a dozen states are
enforcing extreme abortion bans make no
mistake about it Congress passes a
national ban I will veto it
let's remember the world's watching
I spoke in this chamber one year ago
just days after Vladimir Putin Unleashed
his brutal attack against Ukraine a
murderous assault evoking images of
death and destruction Europe suffered in
World War II
Putin's Invasion has been a test
for the ages test for America we test
for the world
would we stand for the most basic of
principles
will we stand for sovereignty we stand
for the right of people to live free of
tyranny
will we stand for the defense of
democracy
for such defense matters to us because
it keeps peace and prevents Open Season
I would be aggressive and threatens our
prosperity
one year later
we know the answer yes we would and we
did we did
and together
we did what America always does at our
best we LED
we United NATO
we build a global coalition
we stood against Putin's aggression
we stood with Ukrainian people tonight
we're once again joined by ukrainian's
ambassador to the United States she
represents not her and just our nation
but the courage of her People ambassador
as our ambassador is here United we're
in uniting our support of your country
will you stand so we can all take a look
at you
thank you
because we're going to stand with you
as long as it takes
I'm committed to work with China where
we can advance American interest and
benefit the world but make no mistake
about it
as we made clear last week if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did
when in the competition should deny all
of us
we Face serious challenges across the
world
but in the past two years democracies
have become stronger not weaker
autocracy has grown weaker not stronger
name me a world leader
who changed places with Xi Jinping name
me one
name me one
America's rallying the world to meet
those challenges from climate to Global
Health to food insecurity to terrorism
to territorial aggression
allies are stepping up spending more and
doing more
look
the bridges were forming between
partners in the Pacific and those in the
Atlantic
and those who bet against America are
learning how wrong they are it's never
ever been a good bet to bet against
America never
wow
my fellow Americans
we meet tonight at an inflection point
one of those moments
that only a few Generations ever face
with the direction
we now take is going to decide the
course of this nation for decades to
come
we're not bystanders of History
we're not powerless before the forces
that confront us
it's within our power of We the People
we're facing the test of our time
we have to be the nation we've always
been at our best optimistic hopeful
forward-looking a nation in Embraces
light over dark hope over fear Unity
over there's a stability over chaos
we have to see each other not as enemies
but as fellow Americans
we're good people
the only nation in the world built on an
idea the only one
other nations
are defined by geography ethnicity
[Applause]
but we're the only nation based on an
idea
that all of us
every one of us has created equal in the
image of God
a nation that stands as a beacon of the
world
a nation and a new age of possibilities
so I've come to fulfill my
constitutional obligation to report in
the state of the union and here's my
report
because the soul of this nation is
strong
because the backboken backbone in this
nation is strong because the people of
this nation are strong the state of the
union is strong
[Applause]